I'm Greg Sadler I am a professor of
philosophy currently at Fayetteville
State University and I'm here to talk
about my my book advance copy of which
arrived last friday about a week ago it
is called reason fulfilled by revelation
the 1930s Christian philosophy debates
in France and I wanted to talk a little
bit in these videos about what the book
is about how I got the idea for it
what's included in it and why you might
want to get a copy of it and notice a
little bit unusual edited and translated
by Gregory D Sadler and a lot of the
book consists in translations of
documents from the 1930s Christian
philosophy debates the time when the
issue of Christian philosophy was
discussed by philosophers theologians
about 50 of them all told the issues
have never been explored and as great
detail or by so many people in great
depth actually probably not by such
great minds as they were in the 1930s oh
this is a reference point a constant
reference point for anybody who wants to
think about the notion of Christian
philosophy and so what I'm going to do
in these videos is talk about a number
of different topics this one this video
I'll tell you a little bit about the
book so the bulk of the book is
translations of a number of different
documents that up until now have just
not been available in English and in a
lot of american libraries the journals
in which these documents were found just
weren't accessible so this book is good
by adding a lot of new information for
lephone authors who would like to know
more about this period of history and
about the issues that are discussed
there there's also a about a hundred
page historical and thematic
introduction so it's a historical
introduction that I talked about all the
background who the key players were why
they got involved why they conflicted
with each other because uh it wasn't
just a debate between rash and listeners
we would nowadays call them secularists
and then Christian thinkers it was
actually an intra Christian debate in
large extent on one side were 80 Angela
saw and Jacques more attack and a lot of
their friends and colleagues and then
another major side was another Christian
philosopher the the Catholic philosopher
Maurice blown del often called the
philosopher of action completely
original thinker who had a great effect
on French philosophy especially French
tell mysm there were other Catholic
philosophers who thought that there
couldn't be any such thing as Christian
philosophy what we call the move on
Thomas like Fernand van steenbergen and
Leon Noel and Pierre mon or nay there
were also some Protestant thinkers who
got involved although I haven't
translated any of them in this book and
there were some phenomenologist like
gabrielle Marcel who found themselves
involved and all these people discuss
these issues some of them may actually
got quite heated with each other
debating them the secularists or the
rationalist they actually dropped out of
the debates fairly early so all that's
historical background I could talk about
this all day long because because I've
been obsessing over these these issues
and these thinkers for years and years
and years so there's a historical
introduction and you may find
that are useful there's also a thematic
introduction and in it I discuss some of
these documents but I discuss a lot of
other as yet untranslated documents i
would say that now blown dells voice has
been restored to the debates in English
before all we were hearing were bred
year and Joe Saul and more attack whose
works have been translated and to a
lesser extent fun Steinberg now we can
see the wide gamut of the people who are
involved but there's probably I would
say a good eighty percent of the
documents from the debates are not yet
translated into English so there's still
more work to be done but scholars can
know if you get this scholars can now
quite easily catch on to what the main
thrusts of the debate war what the main
lines of argumentation work the book
also includes something that could be
very valuable for scholarship a
chronological bibliography I have been
pursuing this for years and years and
years and I have I think what are all of
the documents that are connected in any
way with this debate ranging from the
prehistory of the debate back in the
1920s all the way through to 2010 there
is unfortunately a book that came out
which i reviewed and it really adds
something to the debates but it didn't
make it in here because this was to the
printers by it by two thousand late too
no not late mid-2010 and we just didn't
have access to that book and that's all
eve oblong shuts Maurice blown della
philosophical life but other than that I
think if you're doing research on these
debates or you're even just intro
that in the conception of Christian
philosophy this is a book that you're
probably going to want to get the other
documents that are currently available
about Christian philosophy original
stones books there's a several of those
out there's a Jacques born attends an
essay on Christian philosophy there's a
few articles here and there but actually
there's also a piece by jewel so in here
there are pieces by some other
lesser-known authors like ontem in Santa
yash Bruno dislodge and of course
Gabrielle Marcel idiom born on Steinberg
and I'd mentioned already blown del we
have four pieces by blown del in this
book I think that's probably enough for
right now I'm going to try posting this
video as my preliminary and as more and
more ideas occur to me I have a load
more and more of them in I think that
this is important to do in part because
we'd have at a time now where authors
can't count on presses to do all of the
work themselves authors have to come out
and speak about their books and the
internet offers just amazing
possibilities for this the technology
that we have currently for disseminating
ideas I think it's quite wonderful and
these are very interesting issues that
are raised in here not just for
Christian thinkers I think that actually
there's there's quite a bit of
implications for other religious
traditions of philosophy you might say
it could there be a Buddhist philosophy
with in modern times or would that by
being religious no longer be philosophy
you can ask the same with any religious
tradition I also noticed that there's
other traditions of philosophy and that
similar questions have been posed about
what their nature would be how they
could be defined and those within those
communities of discourse were in fact
working on that and arguing with each
other so I think that this in fact could
be a book very interesting thought
provoking for non academics educating
people people who have an interest in
the life of the mind of course but I
think not academics can also get quite a
bit out of this if you are thinking
about teaching a class that touches on
Christian philosophy this is probably a
book that you'll want for your fear well
at least for yourself as a reference
work perhaps even for your students
although hopefully it'll be coming out
in paperback eventually these are hard
cover books you know they're they're
never cheap let the libraries by these
perhaps and then if it comes out and
soft cover by those so I'm going to
leave off here you notice I get very
excited about this when I'm going to
start talking and so maybe at this point
I should should cut it and i will post
more of these videos as time goes on